I call the leader of the Opposition
Jeremy Corbyn to move amendment a which
stands in his name I so move mr. speaker
emember day the question is that the
amendment amendment a be made as many as
I've an opinion say aye
of the country now
division clear away the eyes to the
right 296 the nose to the left
327 the eyes to the right 296 the nose
to the left
327 so the noes have it the noes have it
unlock would we now come to amendment Oh
in the name of the right honourable
gentleman the member for Ross Skye and
Lochaber mr. Ian Blackford the right
honourable gentleman to move his
amendment Oh formally probably moved you
the question is that the amendment
amendment o be made as well as our third
opinion say aye
of the contrary No
[Applause]
rather than others to the right 439 the
nose to the left were 327
the eyes to the right 39 the nose to the
left
327 so the noes have it
the noes have it unlock order we now
come to amendment G in the name of the
right honorable under the gentleman the
member for Bekins field mr. Dominic
grieve I'm grateful to the right
honourable gentleman for moving his
amendment formally the question is that
amendment G be made as many as of that
opinion say aye
of the country no the nose to the left
321
[Applause]
the eyes to the right 301 the nose to
the left 321 so the noes have it
the noes have it unlock food we now come
to amendment be in the name of the right
honourable member for normanton
Pontefract and Castleford Yvette Cooper
Cooper deliver the amendment formally
thank you
the question is that amendment be be
made as many as a third opinion say aye
of the contrary no the ice to the right
298 the nose to the left 321
[Applause]
the eyes to the right 298 the nose to
the left
321 so the noes have it
the noes have it unlocked but we now
come to amendment J in the name of the
Honourable ladies member for these are
the great rule Reeves Rachel Reeves to
move with the amendment formally the
question is that amendment J be made as
been as I thought a billion say I the
country no eyes to the right 290 the
nose to the left
322 so the noes have it the noes have it
unlock well do we go come to amendment I
in the name of the right honourable lady
the member for Meriden Dame Caroline
Spellman I don't have a lady to move the
amendment formally thank you the
question is that amendment I be made as
many as are of that opinion say aye
of the contrary No
well the lobby the eyes to the right 318
the nose to the left
310 the eyes to the right 318 the nose
to the left 310 so the eyes have it the
eyes have it unlock we now come to
amendment n in the name of the
Honourable gentleman the member but
ultranumb and sail west sir Graham Brady
to move formerly you the question is
that amendment n be made as many as are
that opinion say aye
of the contrary No
Claire the lobby the eyes to the right
317 the nose to the left 301
[Applause]
the eyes to the right 317 the nose to
the left 301 so the eyes of it the eyes
have it unlocked but the question is the
main motion as amended as many as over
that opinion say aye
of the contrary No
I think the eyes have a
[Applause]